en 2010 les historiens des sciences
Naomi aurasquez et Eric konouey publie
marchand de doutes un ouvrage qui expose
l'étendue de la désinformation
scientifique qui vise à nier l'ampleur
du changement climatique et ses
conséquences probables sur la sécurité
des sociétés humaines ainsi certains
instituts et expertes du domaine ont
visiblement délibérément biaisé leur
recherche pour nourrir la controverse et
banaliser le statut quo dans leur livre
très documenté aurait caisse et Conway
traçant particulier des parallèles
saisissants avec d'autres cases et
verrues précédemment comme la
désinformation scientifique sur le
tabagisme les plus acides et le trou
d'un couche d'ozone dans tous ces cas la
communauté scientifique a été
empoisonnée par des membres malveillants
qui maintenaient le doute sur la
dangerosité des produits industriels et
normalisés l'inaction malgré cette
dangerosité si une énorme partie des
sciences est épargnée de tels trahison
notamment les sciences fondamentales qui
ont que peu d'applications la présence
des normes enjeux industriels ou
géopolitiques dans certains secteurs
doit absolument appeler à la vigilance
il nous faut ainsi peut pas perdre de
vue que la science est menée par des
humains qui peuvent être mis sous
pression notamment sous pression de
publication voire être corrompus ou plus
simplement biaisé par l'influence
parfois malsaine de certaines stars dans
leur domaine or malheureusement dans mon
domaine de recherche à savoir
l'intelligence artificielle et en
particulier la sécurité du machine
learning les enjeux industriels et
géopolitiques sont absolument énormes et
le phénomène de scarification est très
répandu après tout on parle là
d'entreprise plus puissante encore que
des industries pétrolières rien qu'en
termes de chiffres d'affaires à cela
s'ajoute la pression pour publier avec
les salaires murobolants à la clé pour
ceux qui parviennent voilà qui me semble
avoir dangereusement poussé quelques-uns
de mes paires notamment quelques-uns qui
bossent avec ou dans des entreprises
privées à produire diffuser et accepter
des désinformations scientifiques
extrêmement dangereuses des
désinformations qui justifient notamment
le déploiement précipité et massif
d'algorithmes beaucoup trop peu sécurisé
et qui sont d'ores et déjà hackés par
des campagnes de désinformation depuis
plus d'une décennie conduisant ainsi la
montée de l'autoritarisme à travers tout
le monde et même à des génocides au
Myanmar en Éthiopie et en Ukraine de
façon plus dérangeante encore
l'écrasante majorité de la communauté
scientifique me semble avoir fini par
normaliser voir à encourager
l'inattention à cette désinformation
scientifique très préoccupante et à ses
conséquences sociales désastreuses sur
des millions de vie humaine aujourd'hui
je vais vous parler de quatre articles
scientifiques publiés dans des
conférences prestigieuses avec comité de
lecture qui me semble être très
clairement de la désinformation
scientifique dangereuse et pour être
clair je ne prétends pas que le contenu
de ces articles est faux mais plutôt que
la présentation de ces articles en
particulier les titres résumés et
introductions tout ça est volontairement
et dangereusement trompeur à l'instar
d'une publication qui signalerait le
refroidissement d'une région de la
planète et dont le titre serait tout le
globe ne se réchauffe pas
étrangement tous les articles les plus
problématiques que j'ai trouvé sont tous
publiés avec au moins un employé de
Google parmi les auteurs une entreprise
qui s'est précédemment opposée à la
publication d'articles scientifiques par
ses chercheurs et qui a explicitement
exigé deux qu'ils adoptent un ton
positif dans leur publication
scientifique mais surtout tous ces
articles prétendent à tort résoudre les
problèmes de sécurité du machine
learning ou au moins il vise à nier ses
problèmes à l'instar de lobby du pétrole
qui cherche à nier la gravité du
changement climatique ou affirmer que
des solutions techniques finiront par
être trouvées mais surtout on va voir
que cette désinformation est jusque-là
terriblement efficace en dévalorisant
certaines lignes de recherche sur la
sécurité ou en produisant des mes
informations très répandues dans la
communauté scientifique enfin je précise
que bien entendu la désinformation dont
on va parler et restreinte uniquement à
ce que j'ai trouvé lu et pris le temps
de déboguer avec mon temps en très
limité et très occupé par beaucoup
d'autres priorités dans cette vidéo je
vous parlerai aussi de l'énorme travail
de débunking scientifique que mes
fantastiques collaborateurs et moi avons
effectués en publiant des travaux qui
contredisent cette désinformation dont
les revues scientifiques les plus
prestigieuses en machine learning
notamment ne rips et acml même si je
préciserai aussi que nos articles
reçoivent beaucoup moins d'attention et
de citations de la part des autres
académiques que la désinformation
produite par Google et célébrée à tort
par cette communauté scientifique si
vous êtes chercheur en informatique je
vous invite à exiger beaucoup plus de
rigueur de vous-même et de vos collègues
surtout vis-à-vis des affirmations selon
lesquelles les problèmes de sécurité
seraient résolus ou peu crédible la
publication scientifique de ces
affirmations aura des conséquences
majeures sur les algorithmes déployés à
très grande échelle par Google et
compagnie et risque d’ailleurs
d'amplifier des tensions géopoétiques
déjà très préoccupantes je vous invite à
être particulièrement rigoureux au
moment de faire la review des articles
de vos pères de sélectionner les
conférenciers à inviter et de choisir
qui recruter ou promouvoir en plus de
potentiellement gober et propagé de la
désinformation scientifique un manque de
vigilance peut aussi et surtout conduire
à davantage de pro d'algorithmes opaque
mal sécurisé et potentiellement très
dangereux sous prétexte que leur
principe ont été scientifiquement
validés si vous n'êtes pas chercheur en
informatique vous pouvez toujours aider
à alerter la communauté scientifique sur
sa vulnérabilité à la désinformation
scientifique de Google en partageant
massivement cette vidéo notamment avec
des chercheurs en informatique mais
aussi en interpellant des journalistes
et des politiciens ou encore en
participant à des projets de recherche
participative et éthiques en machine
learning comme le projet tournesol je
reviendrai plus longuement sur les
actions possibles en fin de vidéo alors
la vidéo est un peu longue donc juste
pour vous y retrouver on va d'abord
parler de désinformation autour de la
protection des informations sensibles
par des algorithmes d'apprentissage
avant de parler de la sécurité de ses
algorithmes notamment vis-à-vis de
campagne de désinformation et puis enfin
il y aura une conclusion chaque section
est ensuite soudée en sous section dont
vous trouverez les time code en
description allez on est parti
les désinformations scientifiques de
Google la plus simple à comprendre et
celle de la protection des informations
sensibles jusque-là des régulations
comme rgpd le règlement général pour la
protection des données personnelles ce
sont concentrés sur la protection des
données des utilisateurs avec
l'hypothèse sous-jacente selon laquelle
cela suffirait à protéger nos sociétés
contre la révélation publique
d'informations sensibles cependant le
lien entre protection des données
personnelles par exemple les données sur
votre téléphone ou les données
enregistrées dans votre compte Google le
lien entre ces données et la protection
des informations sensibles indirectement
extraite de ces données personnelles est
en fait plus complexe que ce qu'on
pourrait croire surtout dès lors que les
algorithmes utilisent les données
personnelles pour répondre à des
requêtes d'autres utilisateurs du web et
notez que ce problème peut survenir même
avec des algorithmes ultra simples
lorsque WhatsApp vous dit que votre
interlocuteur a bien reçu votre message
il révèle une information que cette
interlocuteur aurait potentiellement
préféré ne pas révéler l'information
sensible c'est à dire l'information
qu'une personne ne souhaiterait pas
avoir diffusé est alors enregistré dans
les données personnelles d'une autre
personne ceci dit le problème de
l'exploitation algorithmique des données
personnelles et bien entendu beaucoup
plus important dans le cas d'une machine
learning après tout ces algorithmes
d'apprentissage sont littéralement
conçus pour apprendre des données si ces
données contiennent des informations
sensibles alors l'algorithme aura
littéralement appris ces informations
sensibles hors de façon très
problématique et dangereuse l'algorithme
qui contient potentiellement les
informations sensibles mais généralement
pas considéré être une donnée
personnelle et rgpd est alors très flou
vis-à-vis des droits et des devoirs de
cet algorithme pourtant si l'algorithme
a appris des informations sensibles les
actions ensuite entreprises par
l'algorithme peuvent largement trahir
ces informations sensibles par exemple
il suffit de regarder les
recommandations faites par l'algorithme
de YouTube en utilisateur pour connaître
les habitudes de consommation de
l'utilisateur bref tout objet obtenu à
partir d'une exploitation des données
personnelles y compris un objet aussi
simple qu'une recommandation est un
vecteur de fuite essentiel
d'informations sensibles pire encore les
algorithmes de langage sont souvent
conçus pour littéralement recraché ce
qu'ils ont appris avec presque toujours
très peu sinon aucune distinction entre
les informations publiques et les
informations sensibles en demandant à
ces algorithmes de remplir des
formulaires semi-remplies des chercheurs
ont ainsi montré qu'il était parfois
possible de récupérer des informations
personnelles de vrais individus humains
tandis que d'autres utilisateurs
d'autres algorithmes de langage
informatique notamment ont montré que
l'algorithme exposait des clés secrètes
privées de façon plus préoccupante
encore au fur et à mesure que les
algorithmes de langage se développent il
faut s’attendre à ce que nos téléphones
disposent petit à petit d'algorithmes de
langage très sophistiqué pour faire
l'auto-complétion de nos messages sur
nos claviers intelligents dès lors il
pourra un jour être possible de taper
monsieur fille a dit hier soir à sa
femme que et de tout simplement lire
l'autocomplétion par Google jboard pour
ensuite extraire des informations
potentiellement très sensibles le
déploiement massif de telles algorithmes
sera alors très clairement dangereux
devant ses risques évidents Google a
bien dû s'attaquer à la sécurisation de
ces algorithmes et donc comment s'y
prennent-ils l'ont-ils fait avec sérieux
rigueur et transparence ont-ils été à la
hauteur des énormes enjeux sociaux en
jeu
en 2015 Google a proposé un algorithme
d'apprentissage distribué qu'ils ont
appelé l'apprentissage fédéré ou
fédérité de learning en anglais ce
système est capable d'apprendre des
données des utilisateurs sans jamais que
ces données ne soient transférées au
serveur de Google en gros au lieu
d'envoyer les données chaque téléphone
des utilisateurs va utiliser des
algorithmes liés au fameux réseau de
neurones pour calculer ce qu'on appelle
un modèle ou un gradient et c'est cet
objet qui est ensuite transféré au
serveur de Google les chercheurs de
Google ont ensuite été déployé leur
système d'apprentissage fédérés sur les
téléphones de millions d'utilisateurs
pour apprendre ce que ces utilisateurs
tapent sur leur clavier intelligent
duboard or ces données contiennent des
informations potentiellement
incroyablesment sensibles réfléchissez-y
il n'y a peut-être rien de plus intime
que ceux que vous tapez sur le clavier
de votre téléphone surtout sur des
messager privés comme signal ou WhatsApp
qui plus est l'information dans ces
données peut être aussi sensible pour
votre interlocuteur que pour vous elle
peut même être sensible pour un tiers si
vous parlez de lui et bien sûr tout cela
est fait sans le consentement éclairé
des utilisateurs en tout cas les
articles ne parlent pas du tout de
consentement je cite pour cette étude
des entrées ont été collectées de la
population anglophone d'utilisateurs de
j-bord aux États-Unis en fait si vous
utilisez un clavier jboard par défaut
tous ceux que vous tapez est très
certainement appris par un algorithme de
Google pensez-y notamment si vous
utilisez des messageries sécurisés comme
signal avant que vos messages ne soient
chiffrés vous les tapez en clair sur un
clavier qui apprend très probablement de
ce que vous tapez vu le manque
d’attention à la sécurité par jboard une
gaffe de cette IA pourrait un jour faire
fuer vos communications bref je vous
invite à envisager l'utilisation
d'alternative open source comme
openboard ou unisoft keyboard tout en
restant vigilant rien ne garantit que le
code exécuté sur votre téléphone soit
celui publié sur GitHub en fait pour les
trucs ultra sensibles vous pouvez
carrément désactiver le côté intelligent
du clavier et surtout utilisez une
machine moins vulnérable que le
téléphone comme un ordinateur
mais ce n'est pas là le plus grave ce
qui est extrêmement dangereux c'est que
Google est parvenu à propager la
désinformation scientifique selon
laquelle l'apprentissage fédéré protège
les données des utilisateurs je cite un
article de blog de Google
l'apprentissage fédéré permet des
modèles plus intelligents avec moins de
latence et moins de consommation
énergétique tout en garantissant la
priveci tout en garantissant la privacy
quel désinformation
cette désinformation s'est retrouvée
publiée dans la littérature scientifique
dans cet article scientifique accepté à
publication à CCS 2017 au titre
incroyablement trompeur agrégation
sécurisée pratique pour du machine
learning qui préserve la privacy le
résumé de cet article propage à son tour
des informations trompeuses comme je
cite nous prouvons la sécurité de notre
protocole dans des contextes
d'utilisation honnêtes mais curieux et
activement adversario alors je n'ai pas
traduit le mot privacy parce qu'il y a
des faciliter légale dans le choix de
traduction mais pour le chercheur
machine learning qui connaît mal le
sujet ou pour le législateur qu'il y en
diagonale cette phrase donne
l'impression que l'apprentissage fédéré
garantit la protection des informations
sensibles il s'agit là de l'une des plus
claires et des plus graves des
informations scientifiques d'aujourd'hui
et pourtant cette désinformation est
triviale à des bonnes quais en effet
l'apprentissage fédéré est tout
simplement une procédure plus
sophistiquée pour conduire au même
résultat que l'apprentissage centralisé
classique dès lors un algorithme fédéré
aura appris la même chose que ce Cora a
pris un algorithme centralisé y compris
si des mesures de chiffrement à base de
cryptographie au moment ou de secrets
partagés sont utilisés au milieu comme
c'est le cas dans l'article de Google or
depuis environ 5 ans de nombreuses
recherches théoriques et empiriques
n'ont cessé de montrer que les
algorithmes d'apprentissage moderne
obtiennent leur meilleur performances
lorsqu'il mémorise les données
d’apprentissage un phénomène parfois
appelé double disent pour ceux qui dès
lors l'apprentissage fédéré à son
meilleur et qui aujourd'hui en machine
learning ne cherche pas à optimiser son
apprentissage cet apprentissage fédéré
produira infini un algorithme qui aura
mémorisé toutes les données des
utilisateurs Taylor il pourrait être
possible pour n'importe qui de
décortiquer cet algorithme pour
récupérer des informations sensibles
pire encore s'il s'agit d'un algorithme
de traitement du langage il pourrait
suffire de poser des questions à
l'algorithme pour que celui-ci réponde
en révélant les informations sensibles
et ça les auteurs de l'article de
désinformation sont sont bien rendu
compte mais il ne le signalent que dans
le coeur de l'article où ils écrivent je
cite quand le protocole est exécuté avec
un seuil t la vue conjointe du serveur
et de n'importe quel sous-ensembles de
télé utilisateurs honnête ne fait fuiter
aucune information à propos des
utilisateurs à part ce qui peut être
inféré du résultat du calcul cet aveu de
faiblesse dissimulé dans une précision
après une virgule au milieu de l'article
est en fait énorme
particulier le dispositif dans son
entièreté n'offre finalement aucune
garantie de protection des informations
sensibles mais ça les académiques les
journalistes et les législateurs
paresseux qui se contentent du titre du
résumé et de l'introduction comme c'est
aussi mon cas trop souvent on ne se
rendra pas compte or les conséquences
d'une propagation massive d'information
sensible par les algothmes
d'apprentissage pourrait être
catastrophique imaginez le
bouleversement social que cela
représenterait si tout le monde pouvait
tout à coup espionner n'importe qui
d'autre la révélation soudaine de
nombreuses trahisons pourraient
exacerber des tensions et sérieusement
augmenter les risques de violence armées
par ailleurs les secrets d'affaires et
d'état pourraient être exploités par des
entités malveillantes pire encore des
mots de passe de système critiques
notamment pour prendre le contrôle de
données médicales de centrales
nucléaires ou de systèmes bancaire ou
encore des informations sensibles à
propos des humains en charge de la
sécurité de ces systèmes d'information
tout ça pourrait être exploité par des
acteurs malveillants on parle là d'un
enjeu de sécurité nationale voire de
paix dans le monde
bref l'apprentissage fédéré même si les
combinés avaient des affaires de
chiffrement au mot mort ou de secrets
partagés n'offre aucune garantie de
protection des informations sensibles au
mieux il faut y voir un hack technique
pour faire du machine learning en son
conformant à une version faible et très
maladroite du rgpd le règlement général
sur la protection des données
personnelles au pire il faut aussi voir
une désinformation que Google a voulu
faire avaler à la communauté
scientifique avec malheureusement
beaucoup de succès pour légitimer le
déploiement massif de technologie de
surveillance qui permettront une
publicité toujours mieux ciblée
et pourtant de façon très décevante ça a
été désinformation selon laquelle
l'apprentissage fédéré protège les
informations sensibles a été reprise
amplifiée et normalisée par beaucoup
trop de publications scientifiques
l'article scientifique très dangereux de
Google de 2017 a déjà été cité près de
1600 fois par les publications d'autres
chercheurs académiques d'après Google
Scholar 1600 citations en 5 ans dans le
monde de la recherche c'est vraiment
énorme pire encore en recherchant
learning is a privacy on se rend compte
que la désinformation de Google est
reprise telle qu'elle est sans
justification dans un nombre ahurissant
d'articles scientifiques publiés dans
des revues scientifiques prestigieuses
comme Highway security and prevessy
Highway John all of aded incommunication
computing nature communication Edge 6 et
SPML entre autres vraiment le pire
review en machine learning n'est pas une
garantie de qualité et de façon
terrifiante cette scientifiques a été
utilisée pour justifier toutes sortes de
systèmes d'apprentissage fédérés de la
prédiction des cas cliniques de covid 19
à la détection de problèmes de santé
mentale le tout en s'appuyant sur des
informations hautement sensibles qui si
elles étaient connues des proches ou des
employeurs pourraient bien bouleverser
la vie des personnes souffrant de ces
maladies et j'insiste sur le fait que
les cas que je cite ici sont publiés
dans des revues scientifiques à comité
de relecture autrement dit les auteurs
et les revues scientifiques sont fiers
d'avoir reproduit les systèmes
d'information proposés par Google et de
les avoir appliqués au traitement de
données personnelles y compris des
données personnelles hautement sensibles
pire encore en célébrant ses travaux ce
qui conduira des promotions pour les
auteurs au détriment d'autres en
célébrant ces travaux la culture et la
mésinformation au sein de la communauté
scientifique valide encourage et
normalisent le déploiement précipité et
maljustifié de technologie dangereuses
voire le mépris pour la recherche
rigoureuse sur la sécurité mais tout
pendant ce temps Google peut
tranquillement déployer des algorithmes
de langage beaucoup plus sophistiqués
encore avec beaucoup plus de
mémorisation en s'appuyant sur les
données des utilisateurs et le jour où
on les poursuivra pour mise en danger
des utilisateurs ils pourront répondre à
juste titre que les garanties de
protection des informations sensibles de
leurs algorithmes ont été
scientifiquesment prouvés et validés par
la communauté scientifique qui n'a cessé
d'affirmer que l'apprentissage fédéré
garantit la protection des informations
sensibles tout ça c'est extrêmement
dangereux
et malheureusement je peux témoigner à
titre personnel de l'ampleur de la tâche
qui consiste à des bunker cette
désinformation au sein du milieu
scientifique j'ai eu l'occasion d'être
reviewer dernièrement à acml et norrips
deux des trois conférences les plus
prestigieuses en machine learning et de
façon très troublante un article sur
trois en apprentissage fédéré dont on
m'a demandé de faire la revue propager à
son tour cette désinformation j'ai dû
ainsi prendre le temps de faire le
devunking et de cette désinformation
moi-même et c'est quand même très
troublant que de devoir devunker une
chose aussi triviale à des experts du
domaine mais surtout avec six collègues
notamment elle m'a dit lui-même
chercheur chez Google on a écrit un
article qui synthétise les théorèmes
mathématiques d'impossibilité sur la
sécurité et la privacy des algorithmes
très sophistiqués de machines learning
en gros on en vient à la conclusion que
combiner sécurité et performance est
tout simplement impossible et donc si on
valorise vraiment la sécurité des
milliards d'humains sur la planète il
faut
urgemment sacrifier la performance
malheureusement l’accueil de notre
article de recherche par Google d'un
côté et par la communauté scientifique
de l'autre a été compliqué pour
commencer Google dont il nous fallait
l'approbation pour ajouter l'affiliation
Google de Mehdi a mis le papier en
suspens pendant plusieurs mois avant de
s'opposer à sa soumission une affaire a
priori inédite un an après le
licenciement d'intimité
d'ailleurs on avait prévu le coup et on
a finalement soumis le papier avec
l'autre affiliation de Mehdi qui se
trouve être professeur à l’école plus
technique en France mais de l'autre côté
il y a eu la revue par les Pères plus
décevante encore le principal critique
qui s'opposait fortement à la
publication à justifier le rejet de
notre article en s'appuyant justement
sur la désinformation selon laquelle
l'absence d'enregistrement des données
personnelles suffisait à garantir la
protection des données personnelles et
le tout dans un message horriblement mal
écrit et difficilement compréhensible
une revue absolument scandaleuse à mon
goût la revue site aussi l'utilisation
majoritaire de Wikipédia ce qui est une
autre en tout cas si on considère les
algorithmes les plus spectaculaires
comme GPT 3 ou panne qui s'appuie
beaucoup plus sur les conversations sur
les réseaux sociaux vachement rassurant
ou si on considère les algorithmes les
plus influents du monde moderne comme
les algorithmes de recommandation Siri
ou encore les claviers intelligents dont
l'opacité permet même aux entreprises
d'empiéter encore plus sur les données
personnelles si la version alors soumise
de notre article était par ailleurs
critiquéable et critiqué par les autres
revueurs la décision finale de rejet de
notre article aura clairement été
influencé par le principal critique qui
au mieux propager la désinformation au
pire vous voulez empêcher la publication
de critiques scientifiques de la
sécurité du Deep learning d'expérience
certains chercheurs en machine learning
comme finalement beaucoup de monde
détestent qu’on exige deux qui mesure
les véritables conséquences sociales de
leurs travaux et de ceux de leurs
collègues et peuvent abuser de
raisonnement motivés pour justifier
l'éthique de leurs travaux payés par le
contribuable ou par des entreprises
privées en affirmant typiquement qui ne
font que des travaux théoriques directe
ou qu'il existe aussi des applications
positives de leurs recherches ou encore
qui ne sont pas responsables des
mauvaises utilisations de leur
publications ainsi pour défendre
l'éthique de leurs travaux et pour ne
pas avoir à questionner leur carrière
certains académies préfèrent fermer
l'oeil sur les millions de vies qu'il
contribue à mettre en danger depuis
notre article a été réécrit et ressouni
en mode système autorisation of noge ça
veut dire en gros mettez analyse avec
beaucoup d'ajouts de références et
beaucoup plus de pédagogie pour
comprendre la portée des travaux en
sécurité du machine learning aujourd'hui
encore beaucoup trop difficile à publier
dans les conférences prestigieuses et
beaucoup trop souvent ignoré par les
chercheurs en machine learning et bon on
verra avec curiosité ce que les reviewer
diront de cette nouvelle version
alors s'il y a des experts en privacy
parmi vous vous écrivez peut-être que je
n'ai toujours pas mentionné le concept
dominant de la recherche académique en
protection des informations sensibles à
savoir la notion de confidentialité
différentielle bon la vidéo est déjà
très longue donc je ne vais pas pouvoir
prendre le temps de bien expliquer de
quoi il s'agit mais en gros l'idée de la
confidentialité différentielle c'est
d'envoyer des versions brutées des
objets calculés à partir des données
personnelles au serveur de Google de
sorte à réduire la capacité de Google à
connaître ces données personnelles et en
effet on a là une solution dont si on
fait les choses bien on peut prouver
qu'elle protège en partie les données
personnelles j'insiste sur le fait bien
trop méconnu des chercheurs du domaine
que la confidentialité différentielle
protège les données personnelles
c'est-à-dire les données explicitement
associées à une personne comme les
données sur le téléphone de celle-ci ou
celle enregistrée dans son compte Google
or il y a une distinction cruciale à
faire entre ces données personnelles et
des informations sensibles c'est à dire
des informations que quelqu'un ne veut
pas que les algorithmes diffusent
surtout dans le cas du langage des
activités sur le web ou de la santé où
les données d'une personne contiennent
des informations sensibles à propos
d'autres personnes la différence entre
données personnelles et informations
sensibles et majeures par exemple ma
mère peut très bien envoyer mon adresse
personnelle à mon père l'information
sensible qui est mon adresse serait
alors dans les données personnelles de
mes parents et ne seraient pas protégés
en tout cas pas protégé comme la
confidentialité différentielle prévoit
de la protéger de la même manière les
données personnelles génomiques de mes
parents trahissent inéluctablement des
informations sensibles à mon sujet
notamment à propos des maladies que je
risque d'avoir puisque mon ADN est une
combinaison des ADN de mes parents dès
lors surtout si beaucoup de gens parlent
d'informations sensibles à mon sujet mes
informations sensibles risquent d'être
fuité même si mes données personnelles
sont parfaitement protégées pour bien se
rendre compte de l'ampleur de la fuite
et d'informations via ces canaux
indirects je vous invite à voir cette
vidéo ou à lire l'histoire du Golden
State killer qui a été trahi par les
données personnelles de cousins éloignés
bref la notion de confidentialité
différentielle est en fait trompeuse
pour la plupart des cas d'application à
grand enjeu ceci étant dit même à
supposer que la confidentialité
différentielle est un bon concept sa
mise en pratique est absolument
catastrophique comme en parle cette
excellent article je ne rentre pas dans
les détails c'est encore une fois très
long à expliquer mais en gros les
algorithmes des géants de latex n'ont
pas du tout les garanties suffisantes
même lorsque ces derniers prétendent
garantir la confidentialité
différentielle et je vais ne pas rentrer
non plus dans les détails des
réutilisations malsaines et dangereuses
de la notion de confidentialité
différentielle par les gens de la tech
notamment en termes d'asxwashing début
de pouvoir dominante et de silenciation
d'autres problèmes plus graves malgré
toutes ces critiques aujourd'hui la
confidentialité différentielle est vue
comme le Saint Graal de la protection
des informations sensibles par une
écrasante majorité de la communauté
scientifique si bien qu'un algorithme
qui garantit cette propriété est souvent
qualifiée de privacy plus élevé
en 2021 un article accepté à iclr la
troisième des plus prestigieuses
conférences en machine learning à côté
de la CML et norrips avec un titre qui
affirme les grands modèles de langage
peuvent être des systèmes
d'apprentissage fortement différenciés
et encore une fois l'un des auteurs de
cette désinformation scientifique boss
chez Google alors si on cherche
l'interprétation charitable de ce titre
en un sens ok oui ces algorithmes de
langage peuvent être des apprentis
fortement différencié dans le sens où
après avoir été conçu et entraîné dans
un premier temps ils peuvent dans un
second temps continuer à apprendre en
respectant la privacy des données
exploitées pendant ce second temps et
c'est justement ce que fait le papier
sauf que sauf que la performance dans ce
second temps est en gros trivial par
rapport à ceux qui étaient initialement
appris de plus le pas à pied ne parle
absolument pas de protection
d'information sensible dans la première
phase d'apprentissage qui est bien la
phase critique car nécessite beaucoup
plus de données et donc contient
potentiellement beaucoup plus
d'informations sensibles mais surtout le
titre
plus difficilement des bonnes câbles de
désinformation me semble d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus dangereuse mais soyons
clairs non les très gros modèle de
machine learning ne peuvent pas
atteindre leurs performances tout en
protégeant les informations sensibles en
tout cas avec les algorithmes
d'aujourd'hui pire de nombreux travaux
théoriques suggèrent au contraire
l'impossibilité d'une telle protection
des informations sensibles sans
dégradation majeur des performances
comme on en parle dans notre article la
course à la performance dans laquelle
nous sommes complètement engagés à coups
de communiquer de presse sur Dali et
lambda et qui est massivement relayée
par les médias et les utilisateurs des
réseaux sociaux nuira inéluctablement
grandement à la privacy
[Musique]
les algorithmes de machine learning sont
donc une grave menace pour la protection
des informations sensibles et pourtant
cette menace me semble presque dérisoire
par rapport à ceux qui me préoccupe
vraiment ce qui me terrifie c'est
surtout que ces algorithmes amplifient
encourage et normalisent la
désinformation le cyber-harcèlement et
les appels à la haine comme on l'a vu en
Chine en Inde en Éthiopie au Royaume-Uni
au Brésil ou encore aux États-Unis cette
désinformation et cette haine peuvent
conduire à des politiques dangereuses à
des émeutes meurtrières voire à des
génocides de population entière après
l'ONU anesti internationale a reconnu le
rôle criminel de Facebook dont
l'amplification de la haine au Myanmar
contre la communauté des Rohingyas exige
réparation les Rohingya ont d'ailleurs
entamé des procédures de justice qui
exigent 150 milliards de dollars de
réparation ce qui avec la chute du cours
de facebook représente près de la moitié
de la valeur de l'entreprise mais
pourquoi les algorithmes d'apprentissage
favorisent-ils la désinformation et la
haine sont-ils part nature malveillant
leur concepteur cherche-t-il à propager
la haine et la désinformation non sans
doute pas en tout cas pas
intentionnellement quoique
il faudrait très bien que ça aussi
augmente le revenu et leur bonus le
problème c'est surtout que les
algorithmes d'apprentissage moderne sont
généralement conçues pour apprendre et
généraliser toutes les données dont ils
apprennent si leur donner contiennent
beaucoup de désinformations de
harcèlement et de haine alors ces
algorithmes vont répéter généraliser et
amplifier la désinformation le
harcèlement et la haine comme on en a
déjà parlé les données manipules les
algorithmes d'apprentissage
ok mais ne serait-il pas possible de se
protéger contre les contes malveillants
qui produisent ou amplifient la
désinformation et bien en 2021 une
réponse positive a été fournie par
quatre chercheurs dont l'un travaille à
Google oui vous l'aurez compris cet
article accepté par les Pères
académiques dans la très prestigieuse
conférence économics Computing et encore
une fois je pense une énorme
désinformation dans la dernière phase de
son résumé l'article affirme nos
résultats indiquent que les plateformes
en ligne peuvent efficacement combattre
les utilisateurs frauduleux à faible
coût en consommant de nouveaux
algorithmes d'apprentissage qui
garantissent la convergence efficace
même lorsque la plateforme est
complètement
ignorante du nombre et de l'identité des
faux utilisateurs l'analogie avec la
désinformation des entreprises
pétrolières qui prétendent que les
problèmes climatiques peuvent être
efficacement résolus par de nouvelles
technologies est tellement frappante que
j'ai vraiment du mal à ne pas y voir de
malveillance encore une fois il suffit
de se plonger dans l'article pour se
rendre compte cette phrase n’est en fait
valide que sous des hypothèses
complètement irréalistes mais pour s'en
rendre compte vu comment le titre et le
résumé ont été rédigés les
malheureusement nécessaires de se
plonger dans l'article et de prendre le
temps d'analyser les théorèmes ce qui
clairement demande une certaine aisance
mathématique mais une fois ce travail
effectué on se rend compte l'affirmation
n'est valide que si le nombre de
fauconstes est exponentiellement plus
faible que le nombre de comptes
authentiques exponentiellement plus
faible autrement dit il y a 30 faux
comptes alors vous pourrez combattre ces
faux comptes à faible coût avec de
nouveaux algorithmes uniquement si votre
plateforme possède disons 2 puissances
30 comptes authentiques soit 1 milliard
d'utilisateurs humains et pour peu que
les attaquants créent trois faux comptes
de plus il vous faudra plus de vrais
comptes qu'il n'y a d'humains sur terre
mais bien sûr l'hypothèse selon laquelle
Google ne disposerait que de 33 faux
comptes et elle-même complètement
irréaliste souvenez-vous de cette
statistique chaque année Facebook retire
autour de 7 milliards de faux comptes
dans ce contexte non seulement
l'affirmation principale de l'article
est complètement trompeuse mais
l'article dans sa globalité est lui-même
complètement
inutile et pourtant ce papier a été
accepté à la conférence économique cette
computing cette même conférence qui a
rejeté un de nos papiers en 2022 malgré
un review or enthousiaste tout ça parce
que l'autre revueur juge que le sujet
qu'on aborde dans cet article je cite
malgré les affirmations de liens avec le
machine learning ne semble pas important
qui me permet de souligner le fait que
l'acceptation à publication scientifique
est beaucoup plus liée à l'attractivité
voire aux sensationsnalisme que ce qu'on
pourrait croire en tout cas ça n'a
absolument rien de complètement objectif
neutre ou un partiel et ça ça rend
d'ailleurs le processus scientifique de
revue par les paires très vulnérables
des informations qui est une excuse
toute faite pour rejeter des articles
critiques en disant bah c'est pas
important d'autant que en machine
learning beaucoup d'herviewers sont
eux-mêmes des employés de Google ou des
chercheurs indirectement financés par
Google la même année avec des collègues
notamment l'excellence Sadek farad Kani
on a publié à neurips l'une des tops
conférences en machine learning un
papier qui au contraire démontre
l'impossibilité mathématique de se
défendre efficacement face à des faux
comptes indiscernables des vrais comptes
surtout lorsqu'il y a beaucoup
d'hétérogénéité parmi les comptes
authentiques même s'il n'a pas du tout
été écrit avec ce but je pense qu'on
ignorait l'existence même de l'autre
papier à ce moment-là notre article est
un des bonnes Kings de la désinformation
scientifique citée plus haut mais
malheureusement jusque là le devunking
fait moins de citations scientifiques
c'est à dire
que la désinformation qui en a fait 14
la communauté scientifique propage
beaucoup plus l'affirmation complètement
trompeuse selon laquelle la résilience
au faux comptes peut se régler
facilement à coup de nouveaux
algorithmes que les arguments beaucoup
plus solides sur la vulnérabilité
inéluctable des algorithmes à grande
échelle et encore une fois l'enjeu est
majeur puisqu'il permet à Google de
prétendre qu'il maîtrise parfaitement
leur technologie à l'instar de
l'entreprise privée du film dans le CUP
qui prétend pouvoir miner et détourner
seul un astéroïde de plus fort de cet
article accepté et célébré par la
communauté scientifique Google peut
alors affirmer au législateur que des
audits ou des régulations en
cybersécurité sont superflues voire
contre-productif pour la société civile
puisqu'il est scientifiquement établi
qui leur suffit de développer de
nouveaux algorithmes comme eux seuls
savent le faire et pourtant pendant ce
temps les algorithmes de recommandation
sont hackés en permanence car le besoin
et la capacité à y arriver est une
évidence parmi beaucoup d'entre vous
notamment ceux qui commentent mes vidéos
mais du coup si c'est évident pour vous
il faut s'attendre à ce que ça soit une
évidence encore plus pour les entités
puissantes et malveillantes comme des
gouvernements autoritaires ou des
multinationales qui ont des profits à
protéger il faut s'attendre à ce que ces
entités exploitent elles aussi la
vulnérabilité du machine learning pour
biaiser les algorithmes de
recommandation les plus influents du web
mais comme ils ont beaucoup plus de
moyens pour y parvenir que ceux qui
militent pour une information de qualité
il faut s'attendre à ce que les
algorithmes de machine learning soient
beaucoup plus influencés par cette
désinformation que par l'information de
qualité c'est en tout cas ce que ne
cesse de montrer la recherche mais aussi
le journalisme et les licks des géants
de la tech
malheureusement les articles qui
envisagent la possibilité de
manipulation des algorithmes sont encore
incroyablement rares dans les
conférences en machine learning de
manière absolument terrifiante la
quasi-totalité de la recherche en
machine learning fait l’hypothèse
dangereusement irréaliste que les
algorithmes d'apprentissage devraient
avoir pour but d'apprendre et de
généraliser toutes les données
auxquelles ils ont accès avec second
derrière la fameuse hypothèse iid sur
laquelle la quasi entièreté de la
théorie du machine learning s'appuie et
qui suppose que toutes les données sont
tirées indépendamment d'une mystérieuse
vrai loi de probabilité qu'il faut
absolument apprendre une sorte de main
invisible de l'intelligence artificielle
qu'on m'a déjà dit qu'il faut que
j'invoque dans mes articles si je veux
augmenter la chance qu'il soit acceptées
par les reviewer et oui j'ai consigné
des articles qui contiennent cette
hypothèse alors que vraiment cette
hypothèse ok ça permet de faire des
super jolies mathématiques ça permet aux
chercheurs de briller par leur
ingéniosité technique mais au final
c'est un peu comme faire l'hypothèse des
marchés efficients et de l'appliquer à
des marchés comme celui de l'information
de l'électricité ou des ressources
naturelles ok le chercheur peut utiliser
cet article pour se démarquer par sa
virtuose technique et ça va l'aider à
gagner des prix à avoir un job de rêve
et parfois même à gagner des millions de
dollars siffleur avec Google notamment
mais ce faisant le chercheur en dehors
et propage aussi des désinformations et
des habitudes extrêmement dangereuses
pour les sociétés humaines ce problème
est d'ailleurs pire encore dans le cadre
de l'apprentissage fédéré puisque les
participants au système peuvent plus
facilement envoyer n'importe quoi au
serveur de Google et ces serveurs
pourront plus difficilement déterminer
si c'est gradions correspondent à des
données plausibles de plus ces
participants pourront plus facilement
optimiser leurs attaques pour encore
mieux biaiser les algorithmes que tout
le monde utilisera dans les directions
que eux souhaitent l'écrasante majorité
des algorithmes d'apprentissage fédérés
publiés dans la littérature scientifique
est ainsi en fait extrêmement vulnérable
à la première attaque dite byzantine
depuis 2017 pour enfin considérer la
sécurité du machine learning
gravement a prioriser les problèmes de
sécurité du traitement et de la
communication de l'information et Google
n'y est pas pour rien dans cette des
priorisation
clairement la recherche qui révèle les
vulnérabilités de sécurité de
l'apprentissage fédéré est très gênante
pour des entreprises comme Google qui
voyaient l'avenir de leur business de
publicité ciblée et de recommandations
de contenu et c'est sans doute ça qui
les a motivés à encourager et financer
une recherche qui vise clairement à
dénigrer la recherche sur la sécurité et
à ma grande déception l'article de
désinformation ainsi produit dont l'un
des auteurs est un chercheur de Google a
été accepté par les communautés
scientifiques dans la revue ice Tripoli
security and prevessy je cite le résumé
de l'article nous présentons une analyse
critique des attaques dans des
environnements d'apprentissage fédérés
pratique et de production nos résultats
sont plutôt surprenants contrairement à
la croyance établie nous montrons que
l'apprentissage fédéré est très robuste
en pratique même en utilisant des
défenses simples et peu coûteuses vu les
nombreuses formulations trompeuses de
ces phrases ne fait essentiellement
aucun doute à mes yeux qu'il s'agit là
de désinformation intentionnelle en bref
le point le plus important à retenir
pour des bonnes CACES des informations
c'est que l'environnement pratique et de
production considérée par cet article
n'est absolument pas l'environnement
pratique et de production des
algorithmes déployés à très grande
échelle et avec des enjeux géopolitiques
majeurs en effet l’article étudie
exclusivement la classification d'image
pour deux jeux de données standard à
savoir liste et si Fardi typiquement
reconnaître qu'il y a un 3 dans cette
image et que ceci est un camion ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que ces tâches sont
extrêmement faciles surtout en
comparaison de ce qu'on exige des
algorithmes de langage ou de
recommandations mais alors la robustesse
dans ces cas simples ne dit en fait
presque rien de la robustesse dans des
vraies cases d'applications beaucoup
plus complexes en particulier il me
semble dangereusement mensonger de
prétendre que l'article en question
correspond à la pratique ou en
l'environnement de production c'est
exactement comme si pour valider une
voiture autonome on l'a testé sur un
circuit fermé et on affirmait
contrairement à la croyance établie nous
montrons que la voiture autonome est
très robuste en pratique même en
utilisant des algorithmes simples et peu
coûteux affirmer cela pour des
applications aussi dangereuses que les
algorithmes utilisés à grande et donc en
fait beaucoup plus dangereux que des
voitures autonomes puisqu’il mettaient
déjà des millions de vie en danger en
Inde au Brésil ou encore en Éthiopie ça
me semble criminel contrairement à ce
que fait cet article la sécurité ne peut
jamais se valider à partir d'exemples où
tout va bien surtout quand ces exemples
ne sont pas représentatifs de l'énorme
diversité des cas d'applications et des
attaques que rencontreront les systèmes
qu'on veut sécuriser la sécurité exige
des garanties contre toutes sortes
d'attaques y compris celles auxquelles
on n'a pas encore eu l'intelligence de
penser ou au moins des tests très
poussés et très extensifs sur des
algorithmes qui sont vraiment ceux qui
vont être déployés en pratique on
admettant on n'est pas capable de tester
toutes les attaques auxquelles nos
algorithmes seront confrontés affirmer
une robustesse sans garantie de la sorte
mathématique ou à travers des
expériences très poussées c'est au mieux
dangereusement trompeur et au pire c'est
mettre volontairement la vie de
milliards d'utilisateurs en graphe
danger et autant ok Google est une
multinationale et du coup il faut
malheureusement attendre d'elle qu'elle
agisse comme les et même en pire encore
puisque elle a vraiment les meilleurs
ingénieurs au monde et plus de moyens
encore là où je suis extrêmement déçu
c'est davantage vis-à-vis de la
communauté scientifique qui non
seulement gob et valide scientifiquement
cette désinformation dans des revues
scientifiques prestigieuses mais va même
trop souvent jusqu'à célébrer ce genre
de publication en invitant les auteurs
de tels à prendre la parole tant des
universités et faire ainsi de la
publicité gratuite pour les groupes dans
lesquels ils vont travailler en rendant
Google et Facebook toujours plus cool et
sexy j'aimerais que les chercheurs
soient beaucoup plus méfiants de leurs
collègues qui travaillent chez Google et
beaucoup plus enclins à leur poser des
questions difficiles comme au sujet de
la transparence de l'éthique et de la
sécurité des algorithmes que leurs
employeurs développent voir sur
l'origine finalement questionnable de
leur propre salaire
cette fois vu la gravité de ses
affirmations avec Sadek fraterny et
Oscar villemo notamment on a pris le
temps et fait l'effort de des bonnes
pièces cet article et toutes les
informations autour de la sécurité de
l'apprentissage fédéré dans un article
qui est récemment été accepté à
publication à icml l'une des tops
conférences en machine learning et je
dis ça comme c'était facile de publier
iciml mais c'est vraiment un travail
monumental à abattre qui fait rêver plus
d'un académie voire qui fait rêver des
entreprises en gros l'article de Google
dont on a parlé affirme que les attaques
par injection de données sont bénignes
alors que les attaques byzantines sont
irréalistes notre article débunk ses
affirmations en démontrant que dans les
cadres théoriques prédominants de
l'apprentissage fédéré personnalisé ces
deux attaques sont en fait équivalentes
et donc si l'une est bénigne l'autre
doit nécessairement être bénigne elle
aussi et inverse si l'une est dangereuse
alors l'autre doit extrêmement considéré
dangereuse elle aussi notre article
exploite ensuite cet équivalence pour
concevoir des attaques par injection de
données dévastatrices contre
l'apprentissage fédéré non sécurisé y
compris dans des cas simpliste comme la
classification d'images mistes et
surtout en démontrant l'équivalence
notre article permet d'importer les
théorèmes issus de la littérature sur la
résilience byzantine au cas de la
résilience contre l'injection de données
malveillantes en particulier nous
démontrons l'impossibilité de sécuriser
tout apprentissage fédérés dans le cas
où il y a une forte hétérogénéité dans
le comportement des utilisateurs
authentiques ce qui est le cas en
pratique malheureusement encore une fois
la désinformation de Google a beaucoup
plus de citations que notre article en
l'occurrence 26 fois plus que notre
article qui n'a été cité qu'une fois
j'aimerais pouvoir vous dire que ça va
changer nettement dans le bon sens mais
bon je suis pas très optimiste
ceci étant dit comme nous le soulignons
dans l'article de synthèse de
littérature tout le travail qu'on a
effectué sur la sécurité du machine
learning depuis maintenant 6 ans reste à
prendre avec des pincettes surtout quand
il s'agit des théorèmes positifs de
sécurité en effet c'est théorème positif
de sécurité repose eux-mêmes sur des
hypothèses peu réalistes ou très
problématiques comme le fait qu'il faut
généraliser le comportement de la
majorité des utilisateurs alors bien sûr
il y a des cas d'application ou
généraliser les données et justifiables
notamment lorsqu'on applique le machine
learning à la physique ou à la chimie
cependant cette hypothèse est devenue si
commune et si répandue que très souvent
les scientifiques n'attendent plus de
leurs collègues qu'il la justifie dès
lors le champ d'applicabilité des
travaux publiés et flous et inexpliqués
dans une énorme proportion de la
recherche académique or dans les
applications pratiques les plus
influentes les plus créatives et le plus
dangereuses en machine learning
notamment le ciblage publicitaire et la
recommandation de contenu généraliser
les données revient à normaliser le
statu quo à amplifier les addictions ou
triompher la désinformation ce qui me
semble terriblement dangereux pour les
sociétés humaines et le problème n'est
pas limité à des histoires de faux
comptes même en supposant l'absence de
tout fauconte ce qui est complètement
irréaliste mais selon charitable à
l'instant le comportement de beaucoup de
comptes authentiques peut-être très
indésirable à apprendre et à généraliser
comme on l'a vu par exemple ou dans le
cas de taïwes cette IA de Microsoft a
appris de compte troll mais probablement
authentique et elle a du coup généralisé
leur manière de s'exprimer ce qu'il a
transformé très rapidement en un monstre
sexiste raciste et génocidaire la
désinformation le harcèlement et la
haine sont en fait massivement produits
au moins relayés par une énorme fraction
peut-être même la majorité des comptes
authentiques surtout sur des plateformes
comme Twitter ou Reddit tout algorithme
qui apprendra de ces données même avec
les meilleurs procédures de sécurité
proposées jusque là dans la littérature
scientifique sera avoué répété et à
amplifier massivement beaucoup de
comportements non seulement détestable
mais qui pourraient aussi et surtout
aggraver le déclin démocratique à
l'échelle mondiale
les risques de guerre mondiale il est
urgent que toute la communauté du
machine learning mesure réellement
l'ampleur de la responsabilité que leur
travail implique et des conséquences
dangereuses de leur silence depuis que
Google utilise nos algorithmes à
l'échelle planétaire nous ne sommes plus
des chercheurs dont la science
fondamentale est déconnectée du monde
réel nos choix de sujets de recherche
chez nos hypothèses de travail mais
aussi nos décisions des collaborations à
établir les intervenants à inviter et
des collègues à recruter tout ça joue
désormais un rôle majeur dans la guerre
de l'information sur la sécurité des
algorithmes les plus influents du monde
moderne et sur l'urgence du besoin
d'investir massivement dans leur audits
à chaque fois que nous faisons
l'hypothèse qu'il faut minimiser la
fonction de coût qui cherche à coller
aux données surtout sans souligner les
conséquences d'invoquer ces hypothèses
sur l'inapliquabilité de nos travaux
notamment pour les algorithmes les plus
influents nous célébrons et nous
normalisons l'apprentissage de la
génération de toutes les données
accessibles et nous contribuons à
omettre et à améliorer les problèmes
pourtant largement avérées de
cyber-harcèlement au moment de la
conception des algorithmes à chaque fois
que nous nous questionnons pas cette
hypothèse dans les publications et dans
les présentations des autres nous
normalisons et nous facilitons le
déploiement d'algorithmes qui apprennent
généralise et amplifie massivement et
dangereusement la désinformation et les
appels à la haine et à chaque fois que
nous relions des images produites par
des algorithmes de Facebook des textes
produits par GPT 3 ou des avancées
biologiques de Google deep mind nous
amplifions la publicité gratuite pour la
spectacularité du machine learning et
surtout nous faisons toujours plus de la
sécurité et de l'éthique des algorithmes
une mute news c'est à dire un sujet dont
presque personne ne parle en plus de
normaliser l'absence de contrôle
démocratique sur les algorithmes qui
contrôlent le plus le flux de
l'information et de la désinformation à
travers le monde et si vous pensez qu'il
n'y a rien de mal à célébrer les
avancées spectaculaires du machine
learning c'est certainement parce que
vous n'avez jamais essayé de promouvoir
activement la sécurité et l'éthique du
machine learning et que vous ne vous
êtes ainsi jamais rendu compte de
l'ampleur de l'inattention voire du
mépris que suscite ces sujets pourtant
beaucoup plus important célébrer à
spectacularité du machine learning dans
le contexte actuel c'est un peu comme
célébrer l'ingéniosité de la
construction spectaculaire de stade
climatisé en plein désert c'est
prioriser l'avancée technologique et le
confort du métier de chercheurs en
machine learning aux dépens des
souffrances avérées et dramatiques de
millions d'humains
[Musique]
j'espère vous avoir convaincu que des
géants comme Google ce sont bel et bien
lancées dans la désinformation
scientifique et que celle-ci est
extrêmement dangereuse surtout dans le
contexte de cyberguer et de guerre de
l'information du monde moderne et
malheureusement la communauté
scientifique est en train de gober
d'amplifier et de normaliser la
désinformation de Google mais surtout
les rares a vraiment prendre le temps
d'identifier cette désinformation et de
la déconstruire sont sous valorisés
sous-financés et ignorés voilà qui
semble garantir le triomphe
désinformationnel et dystopique de
Google dans une guerre de l'information
dans laquelle tous les chercheurs en
informatique sont impliqués qui le
veuillent ou non ne serait-ce parce
qu'ils demandent de l'attention des
collaborateurs et du financement
potentiellement au détriment de ce qui
luttent vraiment contre la
désinformation typiquement beaucoup de
ressources que j'avais à ma disposition
notamment des collaborateurs de premier
rangs ont ainsi été volés par d'autres
académiques qui les utilisent maintenant
pour des travaux qui me semblent
beaucoup moins utiles voire parfois
néfaste à la société oui parce que pour
des bunker les travaux de Google comme
je l'ai fait
plutôt au niveau de la communauté
scientifique il faut vraiment beaucoup
d'expertise de temps et de sacrifices je
sais que je me suis grillé vis-à-vis des
entreprises qui sont pleinement engagées
dans la désinformation et ont
littéralement perdu tous les tiques en
plus de mettre fait quelques ennemis
chez eux mais je crains aussi que même
des universités ou des chercheurs qui
peuvent avoir des partenariats très
forts avec Google puissent refuser de
s'associer à moi à l'avenir et alors moi
en fait j'ai d'autres projets notamment
de startups pour fournir des vrais
solutions de sécurité et pour former des
équipes de Data science à la sécurité du
machine learning pour au hasard éviter
d'énormes fuites de données via les
algorithmes de machines learning mais le
problème est souvent beaucoup plus
délicat pour mes indispensables
collaborateurs généralement bien plus
jeunes et moins établis qui charge des
stages des bourses et des opportunités
de carrière il m'arrive ainsi même de
conseiller à des jeunes de parfois faire
ce qu'il faut pour publier comme motiver
le machine learning par dipoteries alors
que clairement ce sera beaucoup plus
probablement utilisé pour faire du
ciblage publicitaire ou comme motivé la
recherche sur l'accélération des
algorithmes par une réduction de
consommation énergétique alors que
clairement il va y avoir un effet rebond
inéluctable et que surtout ça fait
encore de sujets de l'éthique et de la
sécurité un sujet secondaire voire une
nuqueuse malheureusement le monde
Academy gouverné par le prestige et des
métriques comme le h1dex envient souvent
à ignorer l'impact sociétal des travaux
et a tué la carrière de ceux qui ne font
pas ce qu'il faut pour publier publish
en perruche comme on le dit souvent mais
du coup les survivants ceux qui décident
des recrutements et des financements
seront plus souvent ceux qui ont pris
pour habitude et de valoriser ceux qui
font ce qu'il faut pour publier quitte à
surfer sur les tendances souvent
initiées par Google avec des objectifs
lucratifs ou de diversion et quitte à
ignorer les sujets plus difficiles non
publiables et souvent beaucoup moins
cités par les Pères comme la sécurité et
l'éthique pire encore ces scientifiques
établis ont trop souvent encore ce
préjugé tenace selon lequel un bon
scientifique ne doit s'exprimer que sur
la science laquelle doit rester neutre
et impartial alors que normaliser le
fait de négliger la sécurité en faisant
notamment des hypothèses ID on supposant
que les données doivent être
généralisées en fait absolument pas
neutre ni impartial et encore moins
responsable ni scientifiquement correct
en tout cas aussi triste que cela puisse
paraître on en est aujourd'hui là dans
un état du monde académique que la
désinformation de Google mais aussi de
Facebook ou encore d'openaerei à sans
doute chercher et à Clermont réussi à
obtenir à l'instar des algorithmes tant
que les financements et les promotions
dans le monde académique ne tiendront
pas sérieusement compte de l'impact
social des travaux effectués la science
aura davantage la voix de ceux qui ont
le plus de moyens pour écrire des
articles d'apparence scientifiques et il
faut craindre que la théorie du machine
learning prédominante soit celle qui
arrange Google à savoir une théorie qui
ne suppose pas de dangerosité dans la
généralisation et l'amplification des
données ou qui ne garantit la sécurité
que sous des hypothèses irréalistes ou
dans des expériences très restreintes
et alors des banquiers c'est bien mais
construire des solutions vraiment
sécurisées notamment pour la solidité
des démocraties et pour la paix dans le
monde c'est bien sûr beaucoup mieux
idéalement j'aimerais pouvoir consacrer
l'entièreté de mon temps à cela plutôt
qu'à passer mon temps à lire les tissus
de mensonges que Google écrit pour
ensuite expliquer à la communauté
scientifique et au grand public le
danger que ces torchons représentent
mais bon comme presque personne ne fait
ce travail de demonking et qu'il est
quand même important que quelqu'un le
fasse
mais bien sûr ce qui m'anime le plus ce
qui me motive le plus c'est davantage de
construire des solutions pour notamment
gouverner collaborativement de manière
sécurisée les algorithmes en particulier
j'aimerais pouvoir développer des
solutions techniques pour garantir
autant que possible que ces algorithmes
fassent ce que nous voudrions vraiment
qu'il fasse et non pas à ce que des
données incontrôlées téléchargées du web
poussent ces algorithmes à faire et
après maintenant 6 ans de lecture et de
réflexion sur ce sujet précis et 12 ans
de réflexion plus globale sur la
gouvernance collaborative j'en suis venu
à la conclusion qu'un projet
participatif comme tournesol était de
très loin le projet le plus prometteur
pour combattre la désinformation et la
haine et pour valoriser beaucoup plus
l'information de qualité au lieu de
faire l'hypothèse I d tournesol suppose
que chaque utilisateur à ses propres
préférences non seulement sur les
recommandations qui étaient à les
recevoir mais aussi et surtout sur
celles que les autres utilisateurs sont
amenés à recevoir tournesol utilisant
ensuite l'état de l'art en machine
learning sécurisée qu'on a développé
depuis six ans et en particulier un
algorithme appelé pour agréger de
manière équitable et sécurisée les
jugements de nos différents
contributeurs le projet a soulevé de
nombreux autres défis de recherche qui
vont du développement de nouveaux
algorithmes et de la démonstration
mathématique de leur sécurité à
l'analyse empirique des données
collectées en passant par une étude de
l'impact social de tournesol sur les
habitudes de consommation des
utilisateurs une étude que l'on est
encore en train de mettre en place qui
si tout va bien va être effectué
prochainement et vous pourrez être les
sujets mais pour en faire plus il nous
faut absolument faire en fait beaucoup
plus tournesol aura surtout urgemment
besoin de beaucoup plus de moins que les
dons de quelques personnes pour payer
plus de personnes que notre unique
employée responsable aujourd'hui du
développement informatique du site web
malheureusement jusqu'à présent nos 6
demandes de subvention ont tout été
rejetées par diverses entités qui me
sont en fait toute grave en sous-estimé
l'impact monumental des algorithmes de
recommandation et l'importance de
concevoir à nos solutions pour les
gouverner collaborativement dans ces
conditions faute de moyens impossible de
se battre contre Google
des principaux objectifs de tournesol
c'est en fait d'attirer l'attention de
la communauté scientifique sur le
problème de la gouvernance collaborative
et sécurisée des algorithmes en
identifiant clairement des problèmes
concrets dont la résolution aurait des
réelles impacts bénéfiques donc si vous
avez des amis dans le monde académique
envoyez-le cette vidéo engagez la
discussion avec eux sur la
désinformation dont leur milieu souffre
et demandez-leur s'ils ont déjà vraiment
réfléchi à la sécurité et à l'éthique
des algorithmes les plus influents du
monde et si ils cherchent des sujets de
recherche éthiques vous pouvez
mentionner ton seul notamment cet
article en particulier tournesol invite
tout académique à télécharger la base de
données publiques de jugement des
contributeurs cette base de données
contient maintenant presque 50 000
comparaisons ce qui en fait une base de
données comparable à ministes ou six
fardistes qu'on a mentionné plus tôt
mais ça serait vraiment bien qu'on
dépasse la barre symbolique des cent
mille comparaisons et vraiment
convaincante si on dépassé celle des 1
million de comparaisons d'autant que
cette base de données nous semble
beaucoup plus intéressante que ministres
ou si Fardi puisqu'il s'agit de jugement
humain sur ce que devrait faire les
algorithmes les plus influents du web
qui plus est la structure de ces données
ressemble beaucoup plus à la structure
des données collectées par les géants du
web à savoir des données associées à des
utilisateurs souvent ainsi naturellement
les problématiques de privacy et de
sécurité enfin ces jugements
correspondent à des annotations de
vidéos YouTube de qualité les objets
d'étude beaucoup plus intéressants que
des images nistes ou si par 10 en
particulier on peut ainsi espérer
comprendre et généraliser la notion de
qualité d'une vidéo selon des jugements
humains une généralisation qui me semble
beaucoup plus désirable à faire que la
généralisation des comportements des
utilisateurs sur les réseaux sociaux
mais pour être entendu de la communauté
scientifique pour détourner leur
attention de la désinformation de
scientifiques de Google et des
opportunités fantastiques qui avoir à
devenir ami avec eux et pour orienter la
recherche de ces académiques vers les
problèmes de tickets de sécurité de
l'information qui requiert tant leur
expertise leur attention et leur travail
il va falloir crédibiliser tournesol et
valoriser sa base de données publiques
et ça ça dépend énormément de vous vous
pouvez grandement aider à améliorer la
qualité de la recherche scientifique en
intelligence artificielle tout
simplement en créant un compte sur
tournesol et en comparant la
recommandabilité de différentes vidéos
YouTube que vous avez visionnées vous
pouvez aussi contribuer à notre base de
données publiques et ainsi fournir des
données intéressantes pour les
chercheurs académiques en vous portant
garant pour vos amis et en demandant à
vos amis de se porter garant pour vous
et ça au passage ça augmentera aussi vos
droits de vote enfin vous pouvez relayer
les appels à contribuer à tournesol et
par exemple demander à vos
vulgarisateurs journalistes et
influenceurs préférés de parler
davantage de ce projet ou de partager
les liens tournesol plutôt que les liens
youtube notamment pour les vidéos déjà
pas mal notées sur tournesol la
recherche en éthique et en sécurité est
aujourd'hui hackée dénigrés et ignorer
elle a besoin de vous pour s'épanouir et
enfin contribuer à protéger les sociétés
humaines contre les fléaux de la
désinformation du harcèlement et de la
haine